[Music]
biden's got big problems in his own
family though
so ben is gonna be talking about this at
length today but this is
the big shocking scandal of hunter biden
this this is probably the least shocking
scandal that hunter biden has ever been
involved in
but this is the one that's getting a lot
of attention now hunter biden
used the n-word
in a private text the n-word now
how did the n-word become the n-word you
know this is a word i truly i cannot say
it you we all know what i'm referring to
so i don't need to say it
but this word is the only unutterable
word
in the english language plenty of words
are discouraged but this one is
unutterable
and that's a fairly new situation i
actually detail
how this happened in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds which is available now for
pre-order the new york times was
printing this word until quite recently
actually
but now it won't print this word it will
only print the n-word
hunter biden while texting with his
white very
expensive lawyer said things
like true debt n-word now you know
there's
the two kinds of n-word hard r
and soft r okay you know i don't i
i can't say it because if i do i will be
banished to the outer darkness where
there's wailing and gnashing of teeth so
i can't even say it
to just describe it to you but
there's there's one that ends in er and
there's one that ends in
uh and hun and uh is a little softer and
more colloquial and people use it
in a more friendly context and then the
er is
decidedly unfriendly hunter used the uh
okay so he was used i'm not defending
anything that hunter biden's ever done
for that matter
but he was just using this in a private
message now
this is a this is the unforgivable sin
that's what they're going to get them on
that's what they're going to get them on
no they actually he won't he won't face
any consequences for this
even though this is supposedly the worst
thing he's ever done the guy
has used illicit drugs the guy cheated
on multiple wives
and including then shacking up with his
dead brother's widow and then cheating
on her with a stripper
with whom he had a child that he refuses
to acknowledge and that joe biden very
cruelly
refuses to acknowledge joe biden will
not acknowledge one of his
grandchildren good old friendly uncle
joe right oh sweet old grandpa joe biden
just will not acknowledge this girl's
existence
can you imagine you're this little girl
your grandpa's the president of the
united states he refuses to acknowledge
that you're alive all that no big deal
then you had the political problems this
guy was taking that's the personal
scandal
the political scandal is this guy was
shaking down foreign governments
and and taking bribes for political
favors from his father and there's a lot
of evidence that his father carried
through on some of those favors notably
in ukraine
but he was also taking money and taking
meetings in china
for skills that he does not possess
and enriched himself tremendously this
way
doesn't matter there are videos of him
on the internet right now
videos of him with prostitutes overseas
doing all sorts of things of very
dubious legality
from a laptop that was discovered before
the election
that very few people know anything about
because
big tech colluded with the liberal state
to shut it down when that story broke
about hunter biden's laptop you weren't
even allowed
to privately message the story
because there's one set of standards for
some people and one set for another
hunter biden says the n-word he'll be
fine doesn't matter if hunter biden's
not going to get in trouble for taking
bribes and selling out the u.s
government he's not going to get in
trouble for saying a word now if you
said the n word
you you would get in trouble your life
would be ruined hunter biden completely
different
in the spirit of pride month i want you
to know i am i'm really proud
i know pride goes before destruction and
a haughty spirit before fall i am proud
though
of this youtube channel and all you
people who have subscribed that's so
great if you haven't subscribed yet
ring the bell subscribe get the
notifications head on over also to the
audio podcast at apple podcast google
play spotify stitcher i don't know where
myspace
zanga live journal subscribe there to
please leave a five star review we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you